hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen as I'm sure you have
probably seen through just the
bombardment of recent social media ads
some of which I think have unfortunately
ended up on my youtube channel which is
super frustrating so I am sorry about
that but there is a newly repopulate
loss app on the scene called noon now I
say we popularized because the app has
actually been on the market since 2012
but only recently has it been really
gaining momentum and popularity probably
thanks to the massive marketing campaign
but anyways noumic claims to fill the
gaps of so many other quick fix diets
offering long-term weight loss results
through motivation and guidance to make
a true lifestyle change
they actually position themselves as an
anti diet and wellness program and not a
traditional weight loss diet sneaky
language that is super problematic for
lots of reasons that we're going to be
discussing in more detail later on but
since neumes app also makes reference to
several studies that seem to support
their claims for sustainable weight loss
a lot of you have asked me to weigh in
now of course before we get started just
my general disclaimer that the
information in this video is for
education and entertainment purposes
only and you should always speak to a
health care professional about your
unique diet needs also this video is not
in any way meant to shame anyone for
choosing to use this app this is just my
professional review of the platform it's
supportive literature and some of the
potential pros and cons for now let's
start at the beginning so upon
downloading the app and setting up the
account the first thing it asks you is
how much weight do you want to lose I
guess this isn't all that surprising
considering that this app's main purpose
of course is to assist in weight loss
now moving along the second prompt poses
a very
concerning sliding scale where you get
to pick which animal represents the
weight loss speed you want to move at
your choices are either the turtle
rabbit or the cheetah and in case this
needs to be said I just want to start
off with the very simple fact that we
are humans not animals
and obviously we actually cannot simply
choose or will ourselves to lose weight
at a particular speed if we can even
will ourselves to lose weight at all but
we're gonna get more into that in a
minute now with that being said there
are aspects of the new platform that
have proven helpful for some users so
let's start by going through what the
new map actually provides its users
we're also gonna be covering some of the
pros cons and I'm gonna speak to a
fellow dietician colleague of mine who
used to actually work for Anu but left
of course due to her own concerns so
it's gonna be very interesting to get
the inside scoop so definitely weigh
around for that
so first big question what does the new
app provide its users so the new weight
loss app offers eight personalized a
health plan from an online health coach
as well as 24/7 support and motivation
from the coach now like similar apps it
encourages you to log your meals and
your exercise but unlike other apps each
day when you open moom you're met with a
fresh platform filled with new articles
and quizzes designed to kind of test
your knowledge on all things like
Porsche control calorie budgeting eating
less calorically dense foods ways to
hack your sweet tooth breaking up with
bad habits and neumes
color system aka basically a traffic
light system for food which is eerily
similar to the terrible WW kirbo app
that I took down right here but more on
that later
anyway the app claims that by reading
these daily articles
also completing the quizzes and by
following the recommendations of your
personalized coach noon will help you
create behavior changes for sustainable
long-term weight loss this is actually
kind of the whole selling point of new
MIT's behavior change over restriction
which in theory is actually a really
great plan since the research does
suggest that restricting calories
through dieting often does do more harm
than good in the long run for a lot of
people and that by focusing on behavior
rather than the end goal of just weight
loss can actually be really helpful but
is new actually fully on board with that
I am guessing not as mentioned before
new positions themselves as a wellness
program and as an T diet which means
that they're directly targeting a
certain population who is interested in
kind of getting away from traditional
diet culture yet of course when you sign
up you're allowed to choose from two
different options either I want to get
fit for good or I want to lose weight
for good notice that we don't see
options like I want to get healthy for
good or I want to increase healthy
behaviors for good but anyway while the
options in themselves are already
problematic I am seriously confused by
these supposedly personalized options
because regardless of which one you
click on you're guided through the exact
same set of questions with prompts about
weight loss
apparently Noom views getting fit as a
synonym for just losing weight ya know
anyway after just a short time
navigating the app I started seeing a
lot of mixed messages for example one
minute you may be quizzed on the
hypothetical scenario of having a
hundred calories left in your caloric
budget and you're forced to choose which
item would help you feel most satisfied
while the Big Mac at five hundred sixty
three calories
would potentially leave you more
satisfied if you were actually really
hungry the perfect hundred calorie
portion of a half of fresh mango was
apparently the right answer surprise
surprise meanwhile we see the seemingly
supportive non-judgmental and non Diet
eat heads up that it's unrealistic to
eat healthy foods all the time
so instead they recommend a specific
breakdown for low calorie moderate
calorie and high calorie foods to enjoy
spoiler alert dichotomizing foods like
this and giving very specific
percentages of how much you can enjoy is
just another diet rule that you need to
follow so why is noone supposed to even
work well Noom is supposed to work
better than other diets largely because
of the 24/7 online coaching that it
offers the idea behind this is that
there is immediate feedback and
validation for following through with
entering your meals and completing the
readings and quizzes however through
reading different users reviews on their
experience with the app it kind of seems
as if the jury is still out whether or
not these kind of health coaches are
actually real humans or just kind of
BOTS posing as humans in other words
this may or may not be 2020s diet
culture world of Westworld just saying
some users did report that they were
left without responses from their
coaches or that the responses and the
messages seemed automated and kind of
not really personalized for them I'm
definitely gonna be asking my colleague
Caroline later on in the video for a
little bit more insight into this whole
theory that these are not real people
but assuming that these are real humans
which I assume that they are it still
can't be a really great feeling when
you're paying into something fifty nine
dollars a month to be exact with the
understanding that there will be another
person there for you at all times to
offer sound and sensible nutrition and
diet advice so what are the suggested
foods to eat and avoid while you're
following the new app well as previously
alluded Noom uses a trout
light system to categorize food which is
basically exactly what it sounds like
red foods are the most calorie dense and
should be eaten less frequently and in
smaller portions yellow foods have more
calories and or less healthy nutrients
per serving than green foods and should
be incorporated into your diet in
moderate portions and lastly green foods
are the least calorie dense and should
make up the bulk of your diet
unsurprisingly green foods include
things like vegetables most fruits and
whole grains yellow foods include things
like lean meats legumes and low-fat
dairy products and then there's red
foods which include red meats and
desserts as well as things like full fat
dairy products nuts seeds and their
butter and oils essentially this system
depends pretty solely on klore density
to classify foods into their respective
colors which can be problematic if taken
out of context while I agree fully that
some foods are more nutritionally dense
than others and that balance is so
important for overall health classifying
foods solely on caloric density seems to
be bringing us back to the fat phobic
90s no thanks
now the app does specify that no foods
are off-limits
and that the light system is just there
to kind of help with recognizing which
foods are more or less calorically dense
however it doesn't take much of a
stretch of the imagination to recognize
that people could very easily begin to
try to avoid the red foods as they can
be linked to bad or unhealthy options in
fact when logging your red foods if you
go over at all you're met with this
scary red warning sign to limit your
portions conversely you are seemingly
praised both by the app platform and by
on-line coaches when you're eating
mostly green foods in my mind there is a
huge risk that people will develop an
intense fear of all of these types of
red foods while filling their
with excessive amounts of low-calorie
green foods like vegetables and fruits
this to me is feeling like a how-to
guide for orthorexia so while Noom steps
forward from other diets and other
weight-loss apps with the premise that
no foods are off-limits I am left
wondering if that is really the case if
so and people do find themselves feeling
motivated and not triggered by the
premise of these kind of strict
categories then yeah I think Noom could
potentially be a good educational tool
for understanding the caloric density of
different types of foods but that is
really about it we're gonna talk a lot
more about that momentarily but first
the big question that you all have is
new actually a good tool for weight loss
so there are actually some studies
reviewing Noom which support the claims
that using the app faithfully does
result in weight loss one study
published back in 2016
reviewed all of the data input into the
app and compared baseline weights with
end weights for those users that
consistently recorded their meals
exercise and weigh-ins for six months in
other words these were the hardcore
successful users interestingly there
were over 10 million people who had
download the app at this time but only
0.36%
or 36,000 actually used it consistently
I mean I guess I would quit too if it
wasn't working for me but anyways let's
look at the stats what they found were
at this point 3 6 percent of users the
hardcore users 31 percent of users
reported less than a 5% decrease in body
weight around 24 percent lost 10% of
their body weight and 22 percent lost
more than 20 percent of their weight
that is pretty significant if the weight
were to be kept off now at follow-up at
just a year after starting the program
they only had data on half of the
participants and found that just 14
percent were able to maintain at least
10 percent body weight loss now
interestingly this
study is constantly cited without the
follow-up data saying that 77% of app
users lose weight using the app which
sounds pretty good what sounds not so
appealing is the reality that 99% of
users don't stick to the app for more
than six months so yeah I see why they
sell it like they do the truth is even
if the weight maintenance results were
really fantastic at one year one year is
not even enough time to make the claim
that the app helps you lose weight and
keep the weight off for life we would
want to see a follow-up at two and a
half years at five years ten years
fifteen years down the road to see how
these users are doing also it's
important to note that this is really
all self-reported data and when you're
being scrutinized by a seemingly real
human on the other end of the app I
don't know
wouldn't you be kind of tempted and
motivated to fudge the numbers just a
little bit too
now another study that Noom references
in support of their app was done on a
much smaller scale the study took place
with 43 overweight participants with
pre-diabetes who are within one office
setting though by the end of the study
only 36 participants kind of fall
through with the consistent reporting of
the app again not great while the sample
was admittedly small they did find that
64% of the users who completed the apps
online coaching and committed to the
consistent use of the app and coaching
lost over 5% of their body weight now
the issue with this study was that it
was done with a very specific and very
small population and each of these
people were actually assigned a virtual
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention recognized master's levels
coach I know that was a mouthful but in
other words translating the findings of
the study to the general population may
not be so realistic this is because the
average user will not be paired up with
a specialized master's coach and they
likely will not have the unique
motivation of being diagnosed with
prediabetes prior to using the app also
again the users weight loss was only
reported in the study there was no
follow up here to verify if this weight
was kept off in the long term now what
both of these studies found was that
when users were actually more actively
engaged in the app in putting their
meals and exercise regularly weight loss
was obviously more likely and more
successful but we really don't know what
the long-term impact is suspiciously
both of these studies were published in
2016 that's four years ago and yet
they're still to to that new references
most often if new claims to offer
long-term sustainable weight loss then
shouldn't there be updated research
years down the road to prove these
participants kept their weight off in
the long run there should but there
isn't because this long-term data
doesn't exist and if it did it probably
wouldn't be that flattering to their
brand it would not be surprising for the
majority of participants to regain their
weight after the diet as weight loss
interventions typically do result in
early weight loss followed by a bit of a
plateau and then progressive regain it
is also known that after periods of
dieting our bodies undergo physiological
changes including alterations in our
hunger and satiety hormones as well as
our metabolic rate all of which aim to
kind of push our bodies back to our
initial pre diet weight as much as many
people want to believe that you know
this is their body failing them or that
they fail the diet that simply is not
the case we've talked already on this
channel a lot about our body's natural
setpoint range
aka basically where our bodies are most
comfortable weight and shape wise so
even if that number lands you may be
higher on the scale then you may want
just based on what society deems to be
desirable it's largely because
your body's genetically programmed to
know where it's functioning best I am
NOT saying that permanent weight loss is
not possible I'm also not saying that
weight loss will not possess some health
benefits for some people but I am saying
that in a lot of cases purposeful
manipulation of your body through
restriction can often backfire and that
if you do lose weight on a diet just to
gain it back there is strong evidence
that this is not your fault okay so now
let's get into some of the potential
benefits of using this app all criticism
aside there are some top-level elements
of the app that I think may be
potentially useful so number one is
encouraging smart goals if you're not
familiar with this popular acronym smart
goals are specific measurable attainable
realistic and timely
so research has shown that goals set
without a smart framework are less
likely to be attained I like that the
app makes use of the framework and also
encourages the setting of SMART goals
even if in practice sometimes I would
say that the app itself doesn't exactly
walk the talk I will talk more about
this later but it does for example allow
you to make outrageous goals like losing
a hundred pounds in a few months without
flagging that hey no that is not exactly
smart so I'm not quite sure that the app
itself has completely bought into the
smart thing number two is that it
considers eating psychology
unlike most diets this app also
discusses some common aspects of
psychology as it relates to food such as
untangling common cognitive distortions
some of these unhealthy thinking
patterns include all-or-nothing thinking
mind-reading exaggerated thinking etc so
all are nothing thinking refers to our
tendency to think of certain situations
in extreme black or white categories aka
I have to eat perfectly all week or if I
have one doughnut I might as well eat 12
you probably know it well so addressing
these types of unhealthy thinking
patterns can be hugely beneficial for
our overall health and well-being
however the mention of these cognitive
distortions does seem like more of
tokenism than any kind of real tool to
help people begin to understand and
alter their actual thought patterns
essentially instead of diving deep
enough into these thought processes to
make any kind of real difference they
kind of just scratched the surface with
basic definitions and maybe some basic
examples of how they may play out in
your diet journey like cool yeah I mean
all or nothing is definitely a big
problem but what the eff do I do about
it now now number three is the focus on
self-efficacy self-efficacy is the
belief in our own ability to succeed and
this seems to be a pretty important part
of the app success
research suggests that developing a
strong sense of self-efficacy can be
highly predictive of behavior change and
motivation so because of this if the app
really were to help its users foster a
stronger sense of self-efficacy
successful behavior change would be more
likely however their take on
self-efficacy seems to be more of a
requirement of success for the app
rather than an actual tool to develop it
placing the success of one's weight-loss
journey solely on their own
self-efficacy is also a bit concerning
as it really is setting them up for
internalized judgment if or when the
diet fails them so while I do believe
that the above aspects of the app could
be strengths and benefits for its use I
do want to just flag that the mechanism
for their use does not seem to be
focused on the user's growth in their
healthy relationship with food or with
themselves rather again it all plays
into the overarching goal of weight loss
which may not always actually be a
healthy use of these tools so on the
flipside what are some of the downsides
of this app well first
Paul it is still a diet I know they call
themselves anti diet but at the end of
the day this app is still promoting diet
culture and weight loss through
restricting bad aka red foods and
ultimately cutting calories there just
isn't any way that this app can be used
without implementing food rules and
restrictive behaviors one concerning way
that they do this is through food
categories aka the traffic light system
and buy food or calorie budgeting that
they encourage as we know restricting
calories through dieting simply isn't as
cut and dry as it may sound our bodies
do adapt to these diets by compensating
for the calorie loss with changes in
metabolism and hormone production and
they can also potentially trigger
orthorexia tendencies as well again I am
NOT saying that all weight loss
endeavors cause eating disorders
absolutely not
but there is no way that we can pretend
that this dichotomizing of food into
finite categories that you're encouraged
to restrict or budget for is not just
another diet number 2 calories inform
the diet recommendations as alluded to
previously dichotomizing foods according
to the caloric density through the use
of news traffic light system is also a
huge concern this is because it pretty
much is solely using the calories of the
food provides to categorize them as good
or bad to eat or avoid this largely
overlooks the most important nutritional
aspects of our foods the micro and macro
nutrients that they provide to give us
energy and to keep us functioning our
best throughout the day so here's an
example Numa categorizes almonds as a
red food simply because they're higher
in calories compared to fruits and
vegetables that is true however this is
not a bad thing almonds are packed with
healthy fats to keep our brain
functioning properly protein to keep our
muscles and bones strong fiber to keep
us regular and satisfied as well as a
variety of vitamins and minerals to help
us maintain our
we're all health and a robust immune
system avoiding almonds or any nuts or
seeds for that matter because they're
classified as a red food would be a huge
missed opportunity for the incorporation
of some of these healthy and delicious
powerhouse foods number three the use of
unqualified coaches another concern with
the app is the possibility of less
qualified coaches giving diet advice to
users while news website does state that
their coaches are all put through
nuumber City whatever that means there
really is no specific mention of the
coaches being required to be qualified
registered dietitians or any kind of
specific nutrition experts of any kind a
lot of users reviews also mentioned
feeling like their coach was not only
personalizing any information for them
and that may be that they were
potentially even boss so this
generalized format of all people are
receiving feedback from an online coach
who maybe doesn't seem to take a lot of
time to fully understand their
individual needs and or potential
triggers just doesn't seem like
something that I would want to put my
money into instead finding a registered
dietician and seeking their advice and
guidance through whatever journey you
are on seems like a much safer and more
effective way to go about this
lots of RDS also offer virtual
counseling especially right now so if
you are really set on doing this from
home you can at least have the guarantee
that there is a qualified human on the
other side of the line now number four
it doesn't flag problematic weight-loss
goals or disordered eating now for a
supposed anti diet app I am personally
shocked that there is no screening done
for actual disordered eating there is
also a real serious potential for the
app to promote the under consumption of
calories and nutrients so as an example
for myself I input my pre pregnancy
healthy weight and selected my
unattainable goal weight to be thirty
pounds less than that current weight the
app saw no problem with this
even telling me that this was a great
goal to work towards I also chose the
cheetah as my speed for weight loss and
the app told me I would be able to meet
my goal within three months that would
mean losing 10 pounds per month which is
an unhealthy and unrealistic feet in my
books I've even heard of other friends
putting in even crazier goals like
losing a hundred pounds in a few months
no dietitian or any real nutrition
professional would ever give the thumbs
up to that but anyway I want to keep
things
semi realistic for you so I could create
a meal plan that wasn't a total joke and
as a result the data that I input it
generated my recommended intake of
calories to be 1,200 and this was after
indicating that I had a active lifestyle
this calorie budget would have been far
too low to feasibly consume an adequate
amount of nutrients and calories to
sustain my health over time but to put
this into perspective here is a perfect
day on neumes
recommended 1200 calorie budget so for
breakfast I could have a small banana
half a cup of oatmeal made with water
and half a cup of low-fat yogurt for
morning snack just water so yeah that
would kind of suck lunch would be two
carrots half a cup of brown rice a
tablespoon of soy sauce and a small
fillet of salmon afternoon snack I would
get three stalks of celery and three
tablespoons of hummus and then dinner
would be 1 cup of cooked whole-grain
pasta 3 Spears of broccoli and a half a
block of tofu and for my evening snack 1
small apple with a tablespoon of peanut
butter oh I am just sad thinking about
this I am not sure how many people would
really be able to follow such a
restrictive diet for very long I mean I
mean I know I certainly would not be
able to I am literally just hungry
looking at that menu but then finally my
last piece of beef is the daily
weigh-ins now Neumann Courage's its user
to overcome their scale anxiety and to
learn to love their scale which is
highly concerning given the fact that
research actually tells us to do the
opposite one literature view looking at
20 different articles found a negative
relationship between frequent weigh-ins
and psychological outcomes they found
that self-esteem body evaluation and
eating behaviors were all negatively
impacted by engaging in regular self
weighing I know a lot of diets will tell
you to weigh yourself quite often so it
really shouldn't be that huge of a
surprise but the reason that this is
such a red flag for me is because Noom
claims to offer its users the exact
opposite of this a supportive experience
for healthy behavior changes and while
they do cite research of their own it's
important to note that this particular
study concluded that frequent self
weighing at the very least seems to be a
good predictor of moderate weight loss
and that more research is needed the
thing is yes weighing in might very well
increase your chances of loosing weight
but at what physical and psychological
cost I also want to remind you that if
you were to actually get on the scale
every morning you would probably see
some huge discrepancies that would have
nothing to do with what you ate or how
much you exercised for example in
preparation for this video this week I
weighed myself on Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday
and guess what between those three days
there was a seven pound difference your
weight will increase or decrease
depending on hydration salt or carb
intake hormones exercise your last
bathroom visit etc so if you are seeing
your numbers fluctuate everyday like
that while eating bad depressing meal
plan I just cited how could you not feel
discouraged and depressed now at this
point I want to bring in my colleague
Caroline Patrick who is an intuitive
eating dietician based out of Austin
Texas
who actually used to work for Noom two
years ago but of course left due to
professional and philosophical
differences so thank you for joining me
Caroline so tell me a little bit about
your role at noon yeah so I was a health
coach with noon and then from there
there pretty much just two primary roles
that you can take maybe a goal
specialist where you work one-on-one
with users or you can be a group coach
where essentially you facilitate group
discussions among a bunch of different
groups so I worked as a goal specialist
working just one-on-one with users for
the majority of my time
Wow and what are what were some of the
the kind of red flags that you saw with
the app while you were still on the team
yeah I think there are a number
um one thing that really started getting
to me
very quickly was the idea that it wasn't
a diet because there was very clearly a
calorie restriction component people
were counting calories and then there
was kind of like the quality of calories
so from calories are essentially
calculated based on you know you put in
your height and weight and then from
there most people are set automatically
to lose two pounds a week and so they
decrease that amount of calories from
kind of your baseline and you're left
with essentially nothing I mean it's
less than what my forty five pound dog
needs in a day and so it was really
frustrating to me to see that they were
just saying it wasn't a diet when
they're asking people to restrict so
heavily and then from there they have
this kind of food system where they've
categorized foods into either green
yellow or red based on their color
density with a few exceptions
so essentially you know if you have
broccoli or leafy greens that are going
to be really high in water content you
can have a lot more volume for a lot
fewer calories on the contrary you can
you know you have
that are gonna provide a lot more
calories for a lot less volume so that
was essentially how they wanted you to
eat they wanted you to eat a lot more of
those crazy foods and a lot fewer red
foods it was so easy for people to go
over on red obviously because there are
so many foods out of calorically dense
and not even like traditionally healthy
foods like nuts and oils and things like
that and and so there was a lot of food
shaming even from there so they would
kind of vilify processed foods added
sugars refined grains these things were
all really really seen as unhealthy and
that there was a healthier choice to go
for and so I think those were kind of
really big red flags that I saw pretty
you know superficially Wow yeah and
that's that's so surprising about the
two pounds a week thing I mean that's a
lot of weight for people to be
consistently losing every single week I
mean that's that's a pretty hefty goal
so I'm not surprised that the calorie
reduction has would have to beast the
deficit would have to be so great so
that's crazy now looking back as an
intuitive eating dietician now what are
you something what's what's your
greatest concern with people using this
app I think you know there was no really
real assessment in terms of what if
anyone had an eating disorder or eating
disorder behaviors so I think that was a
problem in and of itself in knowing that
probably the majority of the coaches
didn't have any background in that and
on top of that the app promotes a lot of
disordered behaviors and severe calorie
restriction and so I think that is
really really problematic because it's
kind of like you have this app that's
cheering you on you have a whole support
system in it that's encouraging you to
continue engaging in these disordered
behaviors
and finding strategies to prolong those
distorted behaviors and so you know I've
heard them say we're not in the weight
loss business we're in the behavior
change business yeah and so it's like
okay you are putting these people on
really really strict calorie control
control diets and then giving them
behaviors and techniques and strategies
to prolong that starvation and it's
really unhealthy so I think that is
probably my biggest concern is that it's
kind of just giving away for people to
engage with it even longer
oh yeah super super problematic and you
know another thing that I think a lot of
people want to know about is this news
new versity or like the training that
the coaches might have because I know a
lot of people even question whether or
not these coaches are real but obviously
you are real so that's good to know
but yeah what kind of training would all
of these coaches be given yeah yeah so I
will say all the coaches are real there
are some like canned messages and things
like that because sometimes the
caseloads get really high so it's
necessary for us to kind of have that
those kind of flat messages that we can
all send um but so Numa versity is
essentially a health coaching
certification program so it's recognised
by the international consortium for
health and wellness coaching and you
know I actually never went to Numa
versity because it didn't align with
like my dates of employment there so I'm
not sure exactly what it looks like but
from my understanding it's just a health
coaching certification and then you had
to get a certain amount of practice
hours which you would get working with
the app and then at the end of this
certain amount of time and hours met you
take uh sort of like an exam and get
certified so though the health coaches I
mean obviously you're a dietitian but
are all the health health coaches
dieticians or kind of certified and
a degree in nutrition or anything like
that so it was kind of a vast array of
people a lot of people are actually
dietitians some people were
psychologists some people were social
workers some people were had a fitness
background or you know studied exercise
physiology or you know all these other
kinds of health-related fields is where
everyone was coming from but it was you
know I'm clear about exactly how much
nutrition knowledge people had or
awareness around what true health really
looks like very interesting so so that
was not a requirement of the job that
you had to be a dietician necessarily no
and that was kind of sometimes difficult
because I couldn't act as a dietician
like I had the restrictions put on me
because I was only working in my
capacity as a health coach and not a
dietician very interesting and do you
have any insights on kind of a long-term
weight loss success rate for people
using the app I I will say that there
they have done some studies name has
kind of a research team and they do
actually do a lot of academic work but
they haven't produced any long-term
studies I think the longest one has been
a year and we know that that's not a
long-term study maybe in weight weight
loss research that's considered long but
it's really not and so we know that
people have that weight regain within
two to five years
vast majority of people do so you know
it's troubling for me to see their
claims that they are going to help you
lose weight and keep it off for good you
know that's kind of like their tagline
and they have no proof of that you know
I think probably one problem is nobody
wants to be using an app I would assume
for years on end so it's hard for them
to continue tracking everyone Wow
absolutely
yeah it doesn't seem feasible so yeah
very interesting well thank you so much
Caroline for sharing your insights and
kind of behind the scenes in the new
world that's it's really been so
fascinating for us
I'm definitely to be leaving some links
to her website and to Instagram so that
you can reach out for some one-on-one
support so what is my overall take home
on noon well do not be mistaken folks
noon is still a diet and if you've tried
different restrictive weight loss diets
in the past without achieving the
results that you were looking for this
will likely not be any different if you
are truly seeking a positive behavior
change for a healthier lifestyle there
are much better ways to go about it
for example eating plenty of fruits and
vegetables in your day choosing quality
protein sources and choosing whole grain
starches more often than refined also if
you feel that locking your meals is an
effective tool for you and you don't see
any real benefit to those daily readings
or quizzes there are lots of other free
apps that could do the trick and if you
feel drawn to the promise of a greater
attention to the psychological aspects
of eating and behavior change that the
new app always promises I would really
encourage you to reach out to a health
professional like a registered dietician
who can work with you one-on-one to
understand your unique emotional
triggers and strategies all in all if
following the highlighted food rules
calorie budgets and speaking virtually
to a potentially not so well qualified
health coach doesn't seem like the right
path for you I would not recommend zoom
but on that note I would love to hear
your thoughts has noone worked for you
or did you find the app problematic are
there other diets or apps that you want
me to review definitely leave me a
comment below if you like this diet
style review don't forget to give me the
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]